we have this story from Tim cast.com
Trump comments on whether he would
accept house speakership several House
Republicans have nominated the former
president for Speaker of the House Trump
was nominated for speakership by several
House Republicans after California rep
Kevin McCarthy was ousted and we have
this uh here this video from the
post-millennial Let's uh well I'll just
give you the quote because I we don't
need to play the full you know one
minute and 47 second clip all I can say
is we'll do whatever is best for the
country and for the Republican Party
which is to say Donald Trump doesn't
want to say outright no which is to say
he would consider taking this position
if that's what actually happens I don't
think he wants to come out and say yes
of course I'm going to do it it's going
to be great because I'm not so sure he
actually wants to do it I think he's
saying this cuz he's putting a
placeholder in it in the event he has a
meeting with several prominent
Republicans and they come out and say
actually maybe it should be a third
party it should be you Donald and the
funny thing about this is that this was
actually a scenario proposed by a lot of
people you know a year almost a year ago
or I should say you know six or however
many months ago when people were talking
about Speaker of the House people were
saying Trump should get a nominated
speaker this is 2022 this like a year
ago and then after they impeach Biden
and Kamala he becomes
president I mean look anything can
happen I'm not one to make predictions
or dismiss other people's predictions at
this point it's been a crazy crazy past
couple years if you came uh to me at the
very beginning of 2020 and you
accurately icted what the next 3 years
were going to look like I would have
told you that you're completely out of
your mind so I'm not going to dismiss
that it it could possibly happen what do
you guys think there's also lots of
little try to speak into the mic can
there's also lots of little leverage
points from this that are kind of
interesting like you could do it on a
temporary basis and then just stack the
House Appropriations Committee to zero
out the very justice department that's
do that's in charge of the the criminal
proceed I mean there's if you Game
Theory this out him in a speaker
position
with people in the in a caucus who are
willing to to back him uh it could
actually throw a monkey wrench and a lot
of of things that are being done to him
and the question is is if they raise the
stakes this way you know we we're
already seeing what the justice
department and FBI are doing the other
way I don't know if we're even going to
be able to have elections or if it's
going to go full Ukraine style uh if if
a move like that is attempted by Trump I
say screw it put him in there um I think
it's better off than any other
politician out there the paperwork has
been officially filed to even make this
something that's going to be probably up
for a vote so uh why the hell not
Tuesday yeah yeah Matt Gates was call
saying that the Republicans were sending
everybody home to go cry about it that
it's all about one guy because they've
uh uh recessed until Tuesday which
hopefully is good for us for the event
on Friday but Matt's bent out of shape
about it saying they should they should
be doing their jobs and voting on a new
speaker and he's right I wonder what the
point of a recess is to be completely
honest what's what's the
point okay he's out now we're going to
go home no well why wouldn't you just do
your jobs these people don't want to
work yeah politicians don't work they
steal they're professional thieves
they're Liars they're con artists and
they're people that should not be
trusted with any kind of Faith at all so
uh with this news I I think the more
likely scenario I mean we could all kind
of speculate here and talk about Trump
being the speaker of the house but the
most likely scenario here that's going
to unfold is that there're probably
going to be a lot more inviting there
probably won't be a speaker of the house
and because of that there's going to be
stagnation in Washington DC and that to
me is a beautiful thing it's a wonderful
thing I don't want government doing
anything I don't want government running
my life I don't want government to tell
me what to do I don't want more
regulations I don't want more taxes I
don't want more rules I think I think
the situation we have right now is the
most perfect situation for the American
people and that is a Congress that
doesn't have a speaker and can't act you
know what I'm going to be honest I I
usually I don't agree with everything
Luke says I think often times he gets
things wrong I think often even when he
says something correct he says it in
such an indecipherably difficult to
understand way that you can't make heads
or taals of it but I would agree with
most of that I'd be very happy if the
government was less able to do any of
the things but you agreed with that
point I agree with that point yeah I
think you're absolutely right about that
I think you're absolutely right about
that the problem is the house is the one
branch of government right now that
Republicans control and you're you're
basically defanging the one thing right
now that's doing oversight hearings on
everything from Co orins where it just
got released that the CIA was bribing
analysts to change their you know to
change their analysis on Origins that
they were chauffeuring uh fouchy around
into these secret meetings on it and you
all this is and on the censorship side
there were so many uh things like the
Jim Jordan subpoena to get all that if
you neuter the house you sort of neuter
the resistance to the federal agencies
so I'm not I'm more on the put Trump in
there than than shut it down I I think
the more likely scenario is that no
one's going to be in there and to the
point that you brought up gee I I do
wonder why the CIA was bribing analysts
to cover up the origin of the sickness
that we all had to deal with that Echo
Health Alliance and their organization
and other CD parts of the government
were involved in as well I wonder why
they were trying to cover up exactly
what happened to the people of the world
with that particular sickness that they
had their fingerprints on I I just want
to mention Something Mike I think it
turned me around on this one I agreed
with Luke a moment ago but I think I'm
on team Mike here I I would more or less
say that very political answer that's
what a flip-flopping politician would do
I'm willing to change my mind based on
new information I think he made a good
point I hadn't considered it when when
you were speaking my role here is I'm
the arms Supply in the Ukraine Russia
War here so just whoever can get the
arms on their side to to win it I'm
happy to do that but as what what luk
you just said is really interesting
about the relationship between Eco
Health Alliance because you noted they
were involved I mean it was more than
involved usaid paid them $53 million
doar and USA has a very long history as
being a conduit for CIA activity oh yeah
um and you know there's there's a lot
more on that on that particular thing so
so is a suggestion that Trump as Speaker
of the House would be as ineffective on
a lot of core
issues it's more like if there's no
speaker then there's really no ability
to have uh committees functioning in an
effective way and some of the push back
right now on the censorship space coming
out of the oversight committee Judiciary
weaponization house homeand security all
of that is house driven not Senate not
you know not outside only they can
really get access through subpoenas to
some of the sensitive documents but but
people got away the kind of decisions of
what's Happening here because a lot of
people are very critical of of the house
saying specifically they they gave Biden
an unlimited budget they're not
investigating his family they're not
investigating fouchy they're not doing
what they're told they're rolling over
and allowing pure just pandemonium
allowing the Democrats to essentially
have their way with them and some people
are arguing okay maybe we'll get some
committies and some investigation but is
it worth an open border is it worth uh
you know the possibility of World War
III is it worth uh you know unlimited
spending destroying the US economy from
the inside is it worth it how is it that
the Republicans win a majority and it
doesn't change it is the same thing as
it was under Democrats and that is why
it was right for Matt gates to remove
Kevin McCarthy at the very least we get
obstruction and if you remember when the
Republicans won the house that's the
same exact point we made on this
particular show saying about this
particular situation everyone was
celebrating everyone's like we did it we
got the Republicans in not buy as much
as we wanted and thought but we did it
and I'm like this is going to be
Irrelevant this is not going to matter
this is going to be Politics as Usual
and that's exactly what what what
happened until Matt Gates got involved
and said you know what I'm actually
going to try to represent some of the
will of the American people that are
discontented pissed off with Congress
screwing them over but so and and yes
and that's that was my point we kept
saying on this show we want the
Republicans to win more so for the
establishment re anti-establishment
reasons but even if they do we realize
nothing's going to change and it's and
it is to a certain degree worse than
that what happens is when Democrats get
in They smash and Destroy when
Republicans get in they run secret back
room deals with Democrats to smash and
Destroy there is no opposition party in
this country what the Democrats do is is
the machine's agenda and the Republicans
are a pressure release valve for
Americans who are sick of having the
boot stamped all over their face but
they can't stop it now you get Matt
Gates and seven other Republicans who
are saying now we can can put some
pressure on the system and make these
changes with tremendous tremendous power
because they're willing to push back on
Republicans on the establishment on uh
the leadership and they do and boy are
they all losing their minds you know
look I like Lauren bber marger Taylor
green Thomas Massie but I've lost a a
decent amount of respect for them I
still like them they still do good
things but they're their illogical
defense of Kevin McCarthy they have no
justification and I I will spare no one
this there is nothing no logical
argument to the American people who
despise Congress to the to the tune of
82% disapproval for them to say we're
going to keep on keeping on and kick the
can down the road the only thing I if if
I was in Congress
there's no argument you can make yeah
but we're making small gains here and
there Kevin McCarthy is getting us this
that I'd be like nope the American
people despise Congress they're sick of
everything that is that of how this
machine is being run and the omnius
spending bill is basically every single
uh September Congress spits in the face
of the American people and laughs about
it and then finally when someone says
Matt Gates and these other s Republicans
hey you know what we're going to give a
middle finger at the very least to the
Speaker of the House who wants to
maintain the system because the
negotiations work he wasn't going to do
this then what do we see Thomas Massie
say if you do this this institution will
fail good Thomas Massie I don't think
you can make an argument to me maybe
you've got Insider knowledge but it
doesn't matter to me I'm not in Congress
and I don't care other than there is
garbage in these Omnibus bills massive
funding for ridiculous garbage
internationally funding for war that's
never been Justified to the American
people and then say we should be worried
about the institution failing I don't
care I literally don't we must rebirth
that institution and maybe it should be
it should fail so that we can go and
clean up and rebuild it thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net